bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
ce soir sur arte france c'est un projet
essentiel pour les états unis on a bien
souvent l'image d'une amérique ultra
moderne très en avance la réalité est un
peu différente donc l'assiette
oui si vous allez dans une zone en
partie méricaine vous soit choqué l'état
des lapidations ajoutant des niveaux de
sécurité c'est très difficile voire
nationale qu'ils ont l'habitude de
voyager à doha ou dans les grandes
villes dans le monde entier de regarder
les têtes des offres socialisme et
qu'elle dépend des routes tout a besoin
d'une injection d'argent tu es en plus
sacrés de travail pour tous les députés
dans le progrès parce que les routes
sont partout dans les petites
circonscriptions
c'est une ronde politique en vue
économique mais aussi comme vous dites
pour les optiques
d'infrastructures les etats-unis ont
fait ce même constat nicolas conc'air ce
projet de modernisation des
infrastructures on le rappelle donald
trump n'avait pas su le mener à bien joe
biden remporté là un succès on évoque
l'un des plus ambitieux plan de ces
trente dernières années aux états unis
donc je partage ce que les deux glaciers
qui concernant l'état de délabrement
généralisé à des infrastructures
maintenant on va savoir ce qu'on met
derrière c'était en infrastructures sur
ce plan comme on a évoqué qui est
absolument faramineux plus de 1200
milliards de dollars à peine 10 %
concernant à proprement parler la
rénovation des ponts et des routes donc
derrière c'est tout ce qu'on a voulu il
ya intégré et si on avait voulu se
cantonner à la réfection
d'infrastructures d'étoilés route
assurément qu'il y aurait eu un soutien
unanime et que on a vraiment pu parler
d' accord bi partisan ce projet doubler
cette somme on considère que c'est un
projet à minima projet qui donc réduit à
1200 milliards de dollars c'est à peu
près l'équivalent de 2000 40 milliards
d'euros il ne comprend finalement que
580 milliards de financements nouveaux
pis les vidéos ci de l'essentiel de son
volet climatique et de sa contrepartie
financière à savoir la hausse de l'impôt
sur les sociétés
et sur les plus hauts revenus vous
dirais que il a fallu faire des
concessions pour qu'il soit simplement
valider un
dôme créditent au job ride in fact le
vrai génie derrière tout ça c'est nancy
pelosi c'est elle qui a réussi à
rassembler les deux ailes du parti
démocrate vous construire une majorité
de législation il c'était une répétition
si toujours un type alosi qui font le
sale boulot de garder à les deux l
ensemble est coupée souvent de gauche
radicale le parti démocratique oui on a
sacrifié beaucoup de protides le plan
annoncé par hayden mais finalement ce
sont des parties des autres structures
qui dans cette volée l'autre volet ils
vont tuer un débat pendant dix heures
jeux pour avoir beaucoup plus du coupeur
beaucoup plus de déception pour l'ailé
gauche à cause d'eux des élections
et que la converse est ce que vous dire
que c'est le bon moment pour l'économie
américaine appelle projet
le premier perdront un provenir à ce que
ce que douglas est vraiment joe biden
qui lui c'est vraiment lancer corps et
âme dans ce plan qui devait inclure donc
toute la partie et climatiques et
sociales pour un bien 3 il ya eu 5
trillions de dollars donc on était
vraiment à trois fois plus ce qui a été
obtenu et ça c'est juste en voulant
faire plaisir à la frange la plus
extrême du parti démocrate en ce qui
concerne la relance de l'économie on ne
pouvait pas arriver à un moment plus
critique de fait il y à des mesures qui
tend initiée par par joe biden
concernant voilà le l'augmentation du
coût du travail qui génère voilà une
vraie pénurie
les postes ne sont pas pourvus les
entreprises ne pas relancer relancer
leurs économies alors que l'on aurait le
plus grand besoin et voilà quand même
moment il va asséner
toute l'économie avec une inflation
galopante avec ses ce plan ce plan
d'infrastructure considérable et tout en
même temps en imposant un mandat une
vaccination obligatoire dans la majorité
des entreprises et on s'attend à ce que
ça aille vers une généralisation à
toutes les entreprises à compter de
janvier prochain ce qui va là vraiment
aller à l'encontre de la relance de
l'économie toutes ces petites et
moyennes entreprises vous évoquiez
douglas est à l'instant c'est profondes
divisions au sein du parti démocrate qui
ont été révélées avec l'adoption de ce
plan ça va être compliqué pour joe biden
et c'est déjà le cas de mettre en place
ces réformes avec un parti divisé entre
la gauche et qu'on modéré il y a aucun
moyen de se mettre d'accord aujourd'hui
oui il a promis beaucoup de pourrain dit
petit mais c'est impossible les deux
parties sont proposés au fond d'eux ils
croient nous majorité invisible des
américaines qui s'y tiennent le rac 6
nations qui soutiennent l'offre
structure mais une taxe en et en faste
une guerre culturelle qui rassure les
ondes sur internet et dans le midi sur
molex les élections de l'année prochaine
pour voir le l'ailé gauche du parti
démocrate
photo patrick coste rituel contre les
républicains et ça va coûter tous ses
efforts pour construire en milieu un
programme de gouvernance c'est-à-dire on
abandonne vraie politique publique pour
une guerre culturelle sur le télévision
sur internet et l abri dîner et un peu
perdu et chez vous aussi à nicolas
conc'air on voit que ce plan a créé
quelques
tensions dans le parti plan qui a été
validé par une poignée de républicains
moi c'est ça on a des démocrates qui se
font passer pour les républicains qui
voient là ont vraiment soutenu ce plan à
tort donc voilà c'est ni plus ni moins
qu'une trahison c'est 13 républicains
voient la verront sans doute leur siège
être perdus lors des prochains midterms
mais clairement il n'y avait aucun aucun
rien à y gagner pour eux sur ce sens au
plan et les prochaines élections vous le
disiez qu'il devrait qui devrait
perturber aussi peut-être douglas yates
ce prochain volet l'adoption du prochain
volet social et écologique oui nancy
pelosi et c'est dû dépêcher le vote dans
dix jours si elle fait un échec avec
cela il est possible que ce sera le
deuxième volet je suspecte et ont
abandonné le deuxième volet et pendre un
succès sur le premier volet parce que
tout dépend du mystique dicret
république en risque de gagner le
chambre des représentants et comme
nicolas bienne a bien dit il y à des
républicains qui se
montra
républicaine et les votants sont le
maire légende les grandes
électorale indépendante sont prêtes à
voter pour les républicains si les
diamants crac va trop à gauche ce feu
deuxième volet social et écologique elle
est la posture de la majorité du parti
républicain est que la conquête
on a clairement d'autres priorités qui
sont relancer l'économie plutôt que
voilà porter atteinte à des secteurs qui
sont structurées elles qui représente
des dizaines de millions d'emplois on
est vraiment beaucoup plus fort et une
approche libérale moins intrusive moins
de dépenses de l'état et il faire plus
confiance à l'entrepreneuriat et qu'on
soit plus dans le rêve américain que
dans l'entrepreneuriat que dans le
cauchemar socialiste où on arrive dans
voilà une économie qui soit juste
biberonné de subvention de dépenses
publiques merci d'avoir participé à cet
échange ce soir nicolas conquérants
porte parole des républicaines sauveur
six français douglas y est professeur de
droit et spécialiste de sciences
politiques américaines